how are you and I with a book and a TED
talk and a little and a signpost you
know and a tweet you know on a LinkedIn
article like how are you and I gonna
completely change the mind of somebody
whose entire incentive structure at his
company is to drive advice to benefit
his income we're not sure okay at all
and what we can do is continue with the
movement and chip away where you mean
that Business Roundtable making that
statement is a coup for us because it's
like I said we would have been laughed
out of the room you and I having this
conversation on a public forum would
have been the butt of a joke in the 80s
and 90s but now people listen to us and
go hmm that's interesting and even
though there was still many many senior
executives or think you and I are stupid
idealist right and and think that the
reality of the world is not how it works
that way this is the profound profound
strength of the the understanding of the
infinite game which as it turns out that
we we've all been coming to work with it
up here but you know general you know
people have been coming to work with
that sense of discomfort something's not
right here like I don't enjoy work like
I should like it's fine that's how most
people describe their jobs how's work
it's fine
fine right and when we try and say
something we're told you don't
understand how business works and
they're rich and they're powerful so we
just keep our heads down and I guess
they know for me what I've learned what
from this infinite mindset they don't
know how business works business is an
infinite game they're playing for the
wrong game they don't know how business
works and that uncomfortable feeling we
have even though we haven't been able to
put words on it turns out we're onto
something
and all we have to do is keep preaching
and preaching and being the leaders we
wish we had and we will chip away at the
system because we will grow up and to
become the new CEOs when they retire and
die and we will take over and we will
take over Wall Street when they retire
and die like it's it's a generational
thing I am NOT trying to convince
somebody I'm trying to get a new
generation of people now who will
eventually be promoted who will
eventually get jobs who will eventually
apply will eventually start the
companies in
build the companies themselves that in
20 to 30 years from now capitalism will
go back to the capital type of
capitalism that made America what it is
today and Thomas Jefferson owned all the
volumes both volumes of wealth of
nations that it's Adam Smith wrote
America is built on a capitalist ideal
that is not the capitalism we have today
but we can return it it took 20 or 30
years to get to where we are now it'll
take us 20 or 30 years to get back to
where we need to be
[Music]